y
[Música]
argentina celebra de elecciones
primarias para determinar los candidatos
a las elecciones al congreso
34 millones de personas están llamadas a
las urnas en medio de controles
sanitarios por la pandemia tenemos
reporte desde buenos aires
irán permitirá algunas cámaras de
vigilancia en sus instalaciones
nucleares el anuncio llega en medio de
la visita del director del organismo
internacional de la energía atómica oiea
a la república islámica tenemos
información desde teherán
y mientras estados unidos conmemora 20
años de los atentados terroristas del 11
de septiembre el fbi desclasificó un
documento de su investigación sobre la
posible implicación del gobierno de
arabia saudita en los ataques los
archivos no ofrecen pruebas de una
posible implicación
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información internacional aquí en
france 24 y vamos a iniciar el
informativo en argentina porque hoy es
la jornada de elecciones primarias que
definirán a los candidatos de las
elecciones generales del próximo 14 de
noviembre en las que se renueva parte
del senado y de la cámara este ciclo
electoral les servirá como un sondeo de
la fortaleza del gobierno de alberto
fernández que ha tenido que hacerle
frente a la pandemia de kobe 19 además
de la crisis económica y del aumento de
la pobreza por lo que peligra su mayoría
en el congreso en noviembre se elegirán
en 127 representantes de la cámara de
diputados de un total de 257 y 24 de 72
en el senado más temprano conversamos
con nuestro corresponsal
natalio cos hoy sobre las medidas de
seguridad dispuestas en el contexto de
la pandemia de kobe 19 que deja a 113
mil fallecimientos en el país
hola qué tal muy buenos dias angela
buenos días a todos a mis espaldas hay
una escuela aquí en la ciudad de buenos
aires es uno de los 17.500 poco más de
17.500 centros de votación que están
empezando a abrir en todo el país se
sumaron aproximadamente un 20 por ciento
esa es la primera disposición vinculada
con la pandemia para que haya menos
concentración de gente la otra es que se
le pide a los votantes que por favor
mantengan una distancia de 2 metros
entre sí si están haciendo una fila
también hay un horario especial de 2
horas durante la mañana dedicado
especialmente a personas que tienen
alguna situación de riesgo y también
algunas cosas más pequeñas por ejemplo
que quien entra a votar cuando meten el
sobre la boleta o papeleta en vez de
cerrarla con saliva como se exija
habitualmente meta en la solapa del
sobre dentro del sobre como una forma de
cerrarlo y no toque la urna en el
momento de colocar su voto y también va
a haber kits higiénicos en las mesas de
votación para los votantes y para las
autoridades de mesa todas disposiciones
para tratar de prevenir contagios en
este contexto de pandemia en otras
noticias el director del organismo
internacional de la energía atomic a la
agencia de la onu para la inspección
nuclear rafael grossi está de visita en
irán al margen de las reuniones
multilaterales en viena para salvar el
acuerdo que busca controlar el
enriquecimiento de uranio por parte de
la república islámica de que el ex
presidente de donald trump retiró a eeuu
vamos a teherán con nuestra corresponsal
de catalina gómez ángel catalina cuáles
son los avances sobre el programa
nuclear iraní con esta visita
bueno esta visita de rafael grossi
angela era muy importante porque porque
estas cámaras de vigilancia que estaban
dentro de estas plantas nucleares que se
estaban desactualizando muchas de ellas
no habían se habían retirado muchas de
ellas no estaban funcionando como se
debía por falta de acceso a estos
inspectores pertenecientes a esta
organización que dejaron de estar
presentes en irán desde comienzos del
año así que en esto en pista de que la
semana entrante también hay una reunión
de todos los gobernadores desde la
organización internacional de energía
atómica e irán y va a ser el punto
central de esa conversación con la
preocupación del poco acceso que tienen
a estas plantas nucleares y son y
también con la poca vigilancia que hay
pues esta avenida de rafael grossi y la
de las en la confirmación de irán de que
podrían entrar inspectores para renovar
estas cámaras para cambiar las tarjetas
que graban lo que están viendo de estas
plantas nucleares pues es importante
bueno catalina y pese al acuerdo siguen
las tensiones que sigue ahora en las
negociaciones del nuevo pacto
bueno en la
visita de hoy se dice que rafael grossi
va a volver a visitar teherán en las
próximas semanas para hacer ya
conversaciones mucho más profundas sobre
los dos compromisos de irán en este
acuerdo nuclear hay una gran
preocupación porque cada vez acumula más
uranio enriquecido y cada vez retrocede
más en esos compromisos que tiene el
acuerdo nuclear también se está tratando
de acelerar que se vuelva a la mesa n se
está en esas negociaciones para volver a
reactivar el acuerdo nuclear retiremos
que éstas quedaron casi muertas cuando
donald trump se retiró del acuerdo
nuclear en el 2018 y desde la llegada
del presidente joe biden se han vuelto a
reactivar estas conversaciones pero han
quedado estancadas o paralizadas con el
nuevo gobierno de brain rise y así que
estamos en un punto de inflexión esa
visita ha sido importante porque
demuestra que hay voluntad no solamente
a la comunidad internacional sino
también de ir a devolver a la mesa y
poder volver a reactivar no solamente
este acuerdo nuclear sino que también
sus compromisos con la organización
internacional de energía atómica
ciertamente gracias catalina pasamos
ahora de francia anne hidalgo la
alcaldesa de parís y primera mujer en
ocupar el cargo al frente de la capital
anunció este domingo su candidatura a la
presidencia de la nación en las
elecciones del 2022 a pesar de su buena
reputación en la ciudad los sondeos sólo
le dan el 8% del apoyo por debajo de
contrincantes como el presidente
emmanuel macon y la ultraderechista
marine le pen
de cádiz al hotel de ville la socialista
anne hidalgo es alcaldesa de parís desde
el 2014
procedente de una familia obrera tuvo
que emigrar de españa' lyon cuando tan
sólo tenía dos años debido a la
represión franquista allí consiguió la
doble nacionalidad y cambió su nombre de
anna a no considerándose francesa por
voluntad estudió derecho mientras
trabajaba como niñera para costearse sus
estudios tras los que se convirtió
inspectora de trabajo antes de mudarse a
parís donde lanzó su carrera política
desde que entró a la alcaldía la
política del partido socialista ha
encabezado la revolución verde acelerada
en la capital por la pandemia con el
aumento del uso de las bicicletas y las
restricciones a los coches
si estamos en un momento muy especial de
nuestra historia somos la última
generación que puede actuar antes de que
sea demasiado tarde el domingo los
parisinos nos dieron la responsabilidad
de actuar
con dos mandatos consecutivos al frente
de parís hidalgo también ha impulsado
las políticas sociales y se autodenomina
feminista con la lucha por la igualdad
de género en su programa político
dependerá de las mujeres decidirlo
dependerá de los franceses decidirlo
serán ellos quienes transmitan la idea
de que las mujeres en puestos de
responsabilidad marcan una diferencia
positiva en la vida de las mujeres y los
hombres hidalgo ha tenido que lidiar con
la pandemia y el movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos y su carta de
izquierda moderada despierta pasión y
odio entre los franceses con
aspiraciones a la presidencia sigan así
la carrera al elíseo se convertiría en
la primera presidenta mujer inmigrante
de francia en otras noticias en france
el ministerio de justicia de perú dijo
que cualquier manifestación pública en
homenaje de abimael guzmán fundador del
grupo terrorista sendero luminoso será
considerada una apología al terrorismo
delito castigado con hasta 15 años de
cárcel guzmán falleció a los 86 años en
la prisión de máxima seguridad donde
cumplía cadena perpetua
el primer ministro haitiano ariel henry
firmó el sábado un acuerdo con la
oposición y con organizaciones civiles
para un gobierno de unidad en un
esfuerzo por superar la espiral de
crisis política y económica de la nación
más pobre de las américas esto casi dos
meses después del asesinato del
presidente joven él moix el acuerdo
incluye la redacción de una nueva
constitución
y en filipinas a ellas son 17 los
fallecidos por el paso del tifón conson
el que ahora golpea vietnam como
tormenta tropical al menos 7 personas
permanecen desaparecidas y 24 resultaron
heridas otro tifón chanthu hizo que una
terminal del mayor aeropuerto del mayor
puerto del mundo de china suspendiera
sus servicios de carga y descarga de
contenedores este domingo
estados unidos conmemoró dos décadas de
los atentados del 11 de septiembre
cuando cuatro aviones comerciales fueron
secuestrados por al qaeda y chocado
contra edificios emblemáticos dejando
cerca de 3000 fallecidos
[Música]
el presidente joe biden lideró los actos
conmemorativos en los tres lugares la
zona cero de manhattan el pentágono y
shanksville pensilvania al caer la noche
en la ciudad de nueva york que fueron
proyectadas otras luces de 6,4
kilómetros hacia el cielo para
representar las torres gemelas en
coincidencia con la fecha del fbi
público de documentos clasificados de su
investigación de los atentados el
dossier muestra que los yihadistas
tuvieron contacto con personas de arabia
saudita pero no hay evidencias de que el
gobierno de riad haya sido cómplice
entretanto en la misma fecha pero en
afganistán los talibanes izaron su
bandera en el palacio presidencial de
kabul marcando el inicio de una nueva
era tras el retiro de las tropas
estadounidenses que llegaron al país
hace 20 años para capturar al jefe de al
qaeda osama bin laden
20 años después del 11 de septiembre de
2001 los talibanes usan su bandera sobre
el palacio presidencial en kabul en las
calles sus combatientes patrullan en
vehículos estadounidenses fusil m-16 en
mano la ciudad está tranquila y cada uno
se dedica a sus asuntos la única noticia
oficial del día viene del valle de
panchir una vez más los talibanes
afirman tener en su poder el último
bastión de resistencia a su movimiento
en el país
gracias a dios ya no hay ningún lugar
del país que no esté bajo nuestro
control algunos rebeldes que estaban en
panshir han huido hay paz en todos los
rincones del país el sábado es el primer
día de la semana en afganistán y este
sábado no parece diferente a ningún otro
en apariencia porque cuando la gente de
kabul habla de esta fecha es la amargura
la que domina obvios de excepto ámbar
después del atentado del 11 de
septiembre los estadounidenses
estuvieron en el país durante 20 años
por sus intereses
y
los problemas que tenemos hoy se deben a
eeuu y como los eeuu otros países nos
han traicionado y pueden ver el
resultado
mientras varios afganos se sienten
traicionados por eeuu otros como este
hombre agradecen a los talibanes por
traer la paz al país
este fin de semana les contamos que los
musicales de broadway there regresan
después de un cierre de 18 meses debido
a la pandemia de kobe 19 y para los
actores de conforme way hay una
relevancia extra el espectáculo sobre el
11 de septiembre regresa tras cumplirse
20 años de los ataques
18 meses después de su cierre causado
por la llegada del coach 19 los teatros
de broadway se preparan para la
reapertura de sus puertas al público un
momento especial y emotivo para los
actores que se sienten aún un poco
oxidados por no subirse durante tanto
tiempo al escenario
es
extraño estar frente a una audiencia y
en su momento me parece que fue lo justo
sabes quiero decir todo era tan
aterrador durante la pandemia y era una
especie de sensación de alguna vez la
vida volverá a la normalidad
assange gnomos
el musical conforme way cuenta la
historia sobre un pueblo canadiense
pequeño que recibió siete mil pasajeros
varados después de que su avión fuera
desviado a raíz de los ataques del 11 de
septiembre
una historia apropiada de solidaridad y
compasión 20 años después de los eventos
traumáticos que sacudieron el país y la
ciudad hasta los huesos
el momento es perfecto el aniversario
número 20 del 11 de septiembre y la
reapertura de broadway específicamente a
nuestro espectáculo que habla del 11 de
septiembre y de la comunidad miraría los
teatros comenzaron su apertura a
mediados de abril en nueva york pero
broadway permaneció cerrado ya que los
teatros esperaban que las restricciones
sobre la capacidad se levantaran con la
mayoría de los principales musicales
incluyendo a hamilton y el rey león' que
retomarán la próxima semana los artistas
están ansiosos por estar de nuevo bajo
los focos del escenario
y para el cierre de deportes la tenista
británica en manera educando de 18 años
y su historia en el usopen este sábado
se proclamó campeona del torneo y fue la
primera competidora en lograrlo la
británica que nunca perdió un cedé en la
competencia superó en dos sets por 6-4 y
6-3 a la canadiense leila fernández de
19 años educando un número 150 del mundo
también se convirtió en la primera
jugadora británica en ganar el gran slam
desde que virginia weight se proclamó
campeona de wimbledon en
1977 también es la campeona más joven en
17 años después de que la rusa maria
sharapova logró el título de wimbledon
en 2004 cuando tenía 17 años este logro
lo alcanza tras a pasar de los previos
del torneo del usopen
hasta aquí el informativo siga con
nosotros en france 24 y en france 24
punto com donde encontrará la ampliación
de esta y otras noticias muy buenos días
[Música]